let's go next to our caller from the
5:03 area code who's calling today from
5:03 hey David this is Warren from
Portland Oregon again how are you hey
there good it's so recently Russell
embalm mentioned that Trump was referred
to him as like Mr Man and it's it's
become so troubling how so many people I
mean mainly the base has seen
masculinity and Trump as this epitome of
manhood yeah and that fuels their their
judgments towards those that aren't as
man like I guess you know the snowflake
Ryan and all that yeah and at the same
time though I'm curious about your
opinion there's this movement of LGBT
and kind of an awakening of what is
masculine and feminine and I'm wondering
like how you see it kind of coming out
in politics there's coming out I think
in media a lot faster the allowance of
such you know definitions broadened
definitions of masculinity and
femininity but how do you see it coming
out in the political world which I don't
know nearly enough I feel like they know
that it's coming out is extremely
stratified so what I mean by that is the
following take somebody like Barack
Obama now stereotypes around black men
are often about you know hyper masculine
hyper sexualized often in society
including in portrayal in media often
there are you know allusions to the
black man as more likely to become
violent and you know we've studied all
this stuff academically about portrayal
portrayals of black men now at the same
time Barack Obama is a very well
educated the type of person that fits
much more into sort of to use the the
arbitrary dichotomy of the fighter
versus the lover Barack Obama far more
fits into the idea of the lover the
thinker whatever if you look at you know
his relationships with other people how
he interacts with his kids and whatever
where is Donald Trump
in many ways is portrayed and seen by
his supporters as kind of the epitome of
the alpha male and I do think that some
of these roles are changing because
there's a huge swath of society where
when they see Barack Obama not a guy
likely to get into the types of for lack
of a better term pissing matches that
Donald Trump gets himself in into not
the type of guy to make the types of
threats that Donald Trump makes for a
huge part of America that is seen as the
adult in charge in the room way to
behave where Donald Trump despite
checking a lot of the stereotypical
boxes of the alpha male threats loud
boisterous pushing his way around to get
to the front of the picture with the
world leaders insulting people all of
this stuff Donald Trump in reality is
very much the snowflake that the right
likes to portray many on the left to be
so I think the answer to your question
in a very long-winded way is it depends
who you ask for a huge part of the
American electorate those old standards
of alpha versus beta and masculinity
still persist and a lot of those people
are supporting Donald Trump there's a
whole other world out there because we
have a country that is so divided
culturally as much as it is politically
where those norms have drastically
changed and I think that that's a very
good thing yeah it seems like it's in I
hate to stereotype it seems like the
Democrats are pushing an open mindedness
and the Republicans are holding on to a
closed mindedness maybe I can call some
other time and ask but what are the
Republicans here to teach us I mean it
can't be that one-sided or is it I'm not
sure I know what you mean like it seems
like we I feel the Democrat I I'm part
of a group of people who are for
evolving to a place of work we're
teaching the Republicans about
compassion and and what real manhood is
yes power is not insulting its
compassion it looks maybe snow flaky but
it's actually strength yes absolutely
and I don't know that they're getting it
I think some of them maybe are what I'm
wondering is is that one-sided in a good
way I think where we are here to kind of
others get it but that sounds a little
self-righteous just it's not totally
totally one-sided but at the national
level at the national level I think that
it is very one-sided in terms of the
messages we get in media I think in
practice there are plenty of people who
are you know for low taxes who also are
just as empathetic and comfortable with
sort of more modern understandings of
masculinity then then what we see
represented by Republicans at the
national level very important topic and
I hope to talk about it again really
appreciate the phone call of very very
nice to hear from you